foreign
[Music]
and we're only going to do one two three
four pages and the last page is just the
Box
the lesson after that we will carry on
next week yeah so we're going to split
up this lesson into
no costume
we're going to split this lesson up into
two parts so we are on
uh lesson nine uh and that is Page what
page is that
47.
page 47.
47 help him out inside
yeah
you guys found the page
we found it
okay so everyone is to read along yeah
so
I will read you will listen and then
as a congregation after me
foreign
who is this man who are abasan
he is a boss
is a merchant
Ed
Abbas is a rich Merchant yeah Abbas is a
rich Merchant
foreign
what is this
this is a Apple well done
[Music]
well done the apple is a
well done the apple is a delicious
fruits
yeah why
what's feminine
oh
because La Vida is going back to what
and we know that because
[Music]
the principle is
basically if something is feminine and
it's describing that very thing it will
follow likewise in its techniques
meaning in its uh being of feminine yeah
so if something's being described and
it's masculine
the description for it will be in
a masculine context likewise if
something has been described and it's
feminine the description will be where
Tamara bota because that shows it's
feminine in most cases we're going to
find a few exceptions but don't worry
about that now yeah
okay
ah
foreign
that is a sparrow
yeah
you know Supply even I learned a word
the other day
you know what that is
to swallow
type of a bird
I believe I'm saying it right
Insha'Allah it's a type of bird Jannah
yeah they call that swallow the type of
bird yeah huh I don't know
I'm just relaying to you
oh is it so you learn something every
day masha'allah yeah the swallow in
Arabic is called
uh it's full agenda funny enough there's
actually a Makkah
a coffee restaurant or whatever you want
to call it over there called swallow
yeah so yeah it's full of John there's a
swallow yeah but as food is a type of
bird it's a sparrow yeah it's a type of
part in part it is a
but we're done
[Music]
foreign
yeah
language isn't easy
language and obviously in just trying to
read that it kind of went against what's
being said but don't worry it's easy
Insha'Allah
we will struggle today
okay no worries
there's also another way of saying ease
yeah
that's it foreign
they derive from this is that with every
time of hardship by default after that
comes ease
you know hardship comes ease within time
inshallah
Nam
I'm not sure I'm not sure but I know
with that very first day they always
derive the principle within hardship
after time comes ease yeah
uh
okay and we have Lookout another word
for language is lisan
yeah that's why Allah says in the Quran
that he sends the people a messenger
with their lisan meaning their tongue
their language
in the end why who knows
because Lova is feminine remember if the
words being described is feminine the
description would be
feminine so we say I suffer tooth they
said it together I see for two
that's Barrow
almost
asifa is the
description text battle means to follow
the most wolf is the one being described
that's it most of means the one being
described okay
for example if I said to you in Arabic
look I write it for you
yeah kitab one
yeah
who reckons they know what that means
easy means
in this context it has another meaning
but I borrowed this means the expression
or
has another meeting as well but let's
just say
expression for now
that means this book is easy to read
so if I go to uh
it's easy to read so now we can see the
context of how cell is used in Arabic
language this is important yeah don't
worry if you're slightly confused
yeah that will all come later but just
note this down you might not know
it's very clear
uh Nam
also cehalun can mean that which is flat
yeah it can also mean that which is flat
yeah
level land yeah maybe we'll go into
another time inshaallah yeah
okay next page
phone
yeah the Arabic language is a beautiful
language
yeah
Jameel who knows what Jamil means
beautiful it actually comes from the
word gemula to beautify yeah gemula I'll
write it here
gemula
yeah
and then you have
is like its plural I'm gonna write that
down for now okay let's carry on reading
foreign
yeah obviously there's a bit of a
uh how do I say this the gym in Arabic
sometimes in other dialects is left off
some say it yeah like in Egypt some
people don't pronounce the gene in of a
dialects of Arabic yeah I know in the
Emirates who don't say gene they make it
a yeah I'm just telling you guys for you
know possible encounters with other
people of other Arabic dialects some
people say it's actually a lot easier
sometimes but obviously when you recite
the Quran then you have to say the gym
correctly
yeah but you will find like they won't
say Massachusetts
yeah maybe um Morocco I don't know how
to do it regime
yeah yeah
so there is a dialect issue at times
people don't always it takes effect on
me sometimes I said it influences
sometimes yeah
yeah
it came back it's how it affects
laughs
it's like a disease it's modeled
yeah yeah
so okay so
yeah Amar is a hard-working
student yeah
it comes from word you know jihood
means effort
all right here Jim yeah
hey derived from Jordan effort or you
know uh strain hard work
yeah
so it comes from that very root word
yeah the mustard would be
yeah
Jihad you see the words connecting
together now coming from the struggle to
strive yeah it was dead yeah
all right
foreign
[Music]
lazy student
this land comes from the word Castle
which means to be lazy
pump some people don't say kusul
yeah
but Cason
yeah from it is the word now questline
is slightly different keslan means he's
the most lazy
from the Western of fat Lan fatalan
means the utmost possible something of
that very thing so if I say question it
means lazy when I say keslan is very
lazy if I say atosh atash means to be
thirsty but if I say no
very thirsty means angry if I say
very angry so we're gonna get to that
scale fatalan hence the word
the most
merciful see if you see now it works now
okay
uh uh yeah or jehadon yeah so some
people say and there are also narrations
yeah ah for example the Hadith yeah
well done when you say
um
Calamity sometimes
uh turmoil
so he would seek Refuge from these
things
oh Bella that's Bella though
like this look
that's different we haven't come to that
Bella Bella is the way in which you say
yes to a negative question that will
come in book two I believe yeah that's
not yet
will it come later on Bella
Island maybe maybe he's right yeah but
basically Bella is different that's
everything like this
yeah
Bella
we'll get into that don't worry yeah so
ballet which is written like the Hamza
like that is different yeah which means
turmoil Calamity uh
uh you know
fitting can sometimes translate as that
okay
mananta
who are you
yeah so man answer means he will use
kind of rude but no worries
I am a student
are you a new student
s
yes I am a new student
yeah well done okay so you read that
First Hawaiian Arabic
conversation well done
okay
what does tamarino mean
exercises plural yeah
all right we're going to read this
together Insha'Allah yeah and I'm going
to ask you the meaning after
demon
what does that mean
well done old in what sense
well done in terms of profession not in
terms of age in age we don't express the
word when it comes to age we only
express that in regards to
the maybe longevity of something or hmm
say again sorry
again
oh periods yes well done yeah so we
express it in regards to uh the period
of time or the stature of somebody when
it comes to age we say Kabir oh it's
like
he's old in age yeah there are
particular words that
are different to English that we express
with Arabic that even though it
translates as one thing we just wouldn't
say that
if you want to express age it's
different
his young in age in terms of knowledge
all of this will come in yeah
all right next one
what does that mean
is that man a new teacher well done
what's the answer
no he's a new
doctor
my gym
who remembers
it's a bit of a tongue twister I'll be
back
I've been back
back was actually up in there oh it's
got a hamster at the end yeah oh
yeah no worries
okay
what does that mean
s is that easy
listen
ing
what does that mean
say that again
means
famous well-known come to the word
means to you know be famous and known
yeah hence the word yeah means well
known famous sure
means
well known yeah so just write that down
below
what does that mean
big engineer yeah Bilal is a big
engineer well done here
button
I don't think that sentence is correct
it's quite easy to be honest in the
English
sir
so I think that kind of told you the
answer already
the English language
means difficult hard yeah from the words
means difficulty
can you also say also understand that as
an old engineer
you could yeah that that yeah that could
be understood from the context sometimes
generally speaking when it comes to
Arabic a word before that would indicate
it I'm just going to go with the general
sort of like known meaning for now it
doesn't mean it can't mean that it's
true you're right button
okay
what does that mean
yes are you a rich man
no I'm a poor man yeah
yeah
here come some yeah
you know the is
um
foreign
[Music]
obviously I've got a bit of a list
though sometimes I might mix it up but
he's a yeah
uh and the polo
okay
okay so what does that mean
is
Cairo Cairo everyone know where Cairo is
Egypt
it's the capital city
is Egypt Cairo also known as
is known as Cairo Medina
Cairo is a massive City it's massive it
literally is yeah you get lost in it
it's massive it's just full of
congestion and people beeping their uh
Tuk Tuk so if you want to call it
you know those little bikes uh and
they're cars yeah
okay Medina don't forget Medina that
means City that will come back
what does that mean
are you an old teacher
foreign
[Music]
no I am a
well done
well done so is hamide lazy student no
he is a hard-working student
yeah
okay well done
what I feel foreign
uh the next page now yeah
we're reading this uh
we're reading the question from here
yeah
who knows what that means
place
the pen yeah
means place what do you say in Iraqi how
do you say please
um
yeah that's horrible that's proper
Arabic yeah
about Somalia
sir
okay
yeah yeah what happened yeah yeah so far
yeah
okay so what place Phil faragi in the
open empty space
in the sentences that come not 10 what's
not
well suitable well done coming from the
word nasaba nasaba means to be suitable
yeah
Saba
okay
what could that be now
what do we now play store
we could say that
is a new female student well done next
one
it could be so we could say
Khalid is a rich Merchant
Arabic is an easy language
well done
foreign
so the apple is a delicious fruit
you could say that okay
yeah
Adam
that one
we could go with that one or we could
say Muhammad shahirun
yeah Muhammad is a famous
doctor well done
the English language is a
difficult word English is a difficult
language
foreign yeah so this very skill and it
wasn't for our land so I'm going to
write it for you guys fatalan the
Western is actually fatalan
yeah foreign
so all of these words
means forgetful very forgetful oh sorry
regretful not forgetful that's Nissan
Nissan is to do a forgetful to be
forgetful sorry another man is regretful
apologies yeah regretful
uh
uh and I wasn't for Alan which means the
utmost possible of that very thing
I've Shan very very
thirsty yeah
okay
Raton
remember Medina
is
well done so it has to
if the word comes follow it be also
is
in
everyone say mother in
mother in
the Quran foreign
meaning then Pharaoh sent among the
cities
are you
are you he's questioning you Anta
parliament are you a
lazy student
you could say you say laugh you want me
to say Nam Allah
so okay
all right
yeah we just done that okay everyone
foreign
so place in the empty
uh Gap Holly's like that which is vacant
yeah that was just vacant
Phil Germany in the coming sentences
the one being described the same as
mosulf same meaning
suitable so now we look at the sentence
huh
we now we look at the sentences and we
see an Arabia to something it's exactly
what we just did before but now the
opposite way around yeah so I'll be here
too something
Arabic is an easy language
I am an old
teacher yeah
foreign
this is a
broken pen is broken
so all of these words
that's the scale and I was in fact
to say
no
I know
means
very hungry so write this down very
hungry means
very thirsty
very angry malanu
is full
yeah that full that is
to its utmost limit no more can be taken
all right let's read together the
sentences oh let me give you a few words
because Milano like something close in
meaning to that is which means full up
so if you said in Arabic
like Stout and plump he's got Flesh on
him tell it
legitimate write that down yeah
but yeah
you know what just means
body well done
Stout I believe the word is plump yeah
right plump
like a fleshy saw individual
monteleton it's a nice way to describe
him
because you don't want to call him that
fat that's a meme
[Music]
yeah okay let's be together
I'm hungry
are you hungry
no I'm thirsty
what does that mean
why is the teacher angry today means
today
or the day in some context is here
yeah it just means the cup is full
so yeah
yeah yeah
uh play just move on another one I found
out today another word which is very
interesting see if you can catch this
one
yeah well done means he has a big beard
an individual has a big long beard yeah
yeah
for example
means like you know don't have a beard
yeah
I'll run out of board again
ill Taha
ill uh
yeah like to have a beard
like fully
for who I'm will tell him
so he's the bearded man
foreign
next page and we are almost finished
we're in the Box
we see the box and Duke is box at a
Safra on the page two
what does that mean
s
what does that mean famous
what's that mean City or the city yeah
what does that mean but
eliomo
today yeah yeah
[Music]
for example yeah
what does that mean
lazy very lazy
hungry yeah hungry
what is that thirsty well done
foreign
[Music]
this is alluding to
a particular day A Time
we'll get to that another day so if you
see
it would allude to it being we're going
to learn that next lesson Insha'Allah
yeah a type of day or a day being
referenced to yeah
uh which was appeared in time past tense
most times it would be in that context
although uh we won't go into how long
has it been years in
40 minutes so an activity we shall
suffice the next lesson we will be going
into something different which is
a few meanings and hopefully we'll
understand it fully uh